yo got a gift my friend nothing makes me
happier than to see young people getting
involved in the creative arts this is a
prime example
Ted meterage he submitted this logo for
a brand called childish and from a
glance it looks like it's super tight
and pro and it is but when we take a
deeper dive we take a look at this we
can see some inconsistencies in the
letter form I'm going to show you what
to do if you do something like this
tip don't screw that up what do we think
of this logo
I think it's childish topsails yeah it
just feels like it's not done and the
same with the H the loop on the Aged
there's a flat spot right here so it
needs to be more curved like this mm-hmm
I believe that's the same age so it's
got the same problem right he's got a
curve on the top he's got a curve on the
bottom so you have not a fan of the
curves
maybe it's the sharpness of those curves
because they come to a point and
everything else is so rounded yeah
that's what I was trying to say there's
some inconsistent weight issues and I
think the way the sea is coming across
here where it's almost closing in on
this thing you might want to pay
attention to that Ted I think if you
just pulled it back a little bit maybe
bringing this part out what's the
problem now guys can you tell
it doesn't actually follow the lines all
the way through this adds a little bit
more of a fun quality to it so the lines
aren't perfectly straight or a little
wavy and as long as you do it
consistently you're fine
here's what I notice right away though
these are all curved bottoms right
mm-hmm
so why is this one a little short you
might have noticed that the S feels a
little out of place that's the one
letter that stands out because it's a
little narrow mm-hmm there's some issues
with the weight like see how it's really
thick here and not as thick down here so
that's a problem right there
if this were the bottom of the H then
this has to go below that so we need to
fix the s the see the curvature of the H
the tops of the elves which lighter
should I work on first ladies page all
right so I think this just needs to be
turned towards this line here there's a
reason why those guys are there as I
draw these things I learned that if you
keep them parallel to that that it
should start to look a little bit more
consistent with the angles of everything
else has I feel better
[Music]
so you notice the difference between
this one and this one you guys yes we
also have to look at the angle in which
the pen was held the original brush pen
and I think again it's at an angle like
this that's why this part should be the
thickest you should get thick and then
it should get thin at the bottom it's
getting thicker the wrong spot here what
you could not articulate in words is
really what your eye your hearts feeling
and luckily I'm a whisper of letterforms
I can understand it's like I don't deal
with designers with type problems I deal
with type that has designer problems
okay so what we have here is we have a
nice curve so I'm just gonna steal it so
it curves up and it goes to a point but
the point rounds over right so I'm going
to just borrow that now we can compare
that L beautiful just feel a little bit
better guys so much better so you can
have that little kink right there all
right now we have to fix the s give me a
little room dude you're crowding me H
get on my way you see how wide the D is
relative to the s so I copied this line
and that line and moved it over here to
kind of approximate how wide the D is
compared to this well first we need to
fix a couple of things you look at this
is so inconsistent guys these bottoms
should all meet up at the same point
what's the point of having a guide if
they don't you know what that is
decoration no I think it's childish I
want to get into the right spot sorta
before I go and fix everything okay
mommy says it's good it's good for me
[Music]
you might need another point here Ted
and how do I know where the points need
to be
do you guys know no okay thanks
if you draw an O and if you highlight
all the anchor points on it you see that
there's wanting at the bottom yeah one
here on the side one at the time mm-hmm
so there should be one here at the
bottom there's none here on the side
there should be one at the top see so
now you know you need to add an anchor
point right there
[Music]
is it feel too wide now where's okay a
little bit it seems a little bit wide
maybe a hair white so I'm gonna cheat
right now I'm gonna use the scale tool
I'm gonna click right here and I'm just
gonna squash in from side just a hair
speech that's it
anyways we will bring this back now we
need to fix this part dude it'd be there
it's not this I believe could use a
ribbon underneath you know I'm talking
about ladies hey let's draw one and it
wouldn't be sharp like this this would
be kind of a wave like these are so
we're gonna echo that same element so
it's got a little S curve and then we'll
round that corner off later so it need
some work on that on the C but Ted I
hope you like he's commenting yeah all
right let me know if you guys agree or
disagree with the changes and
suggestions that I made and if you like
this video you know what to do hit the
subscribe button and I will see you on
the next episode no idea if you want a
deeper dive into logos check out our
course called logo design and
construction and if you want your work
or teak by us make sure you follow us on
the Facebook page and submit when we
call for your entries see you guys next
time I'm out of here